all right so Zack Snyder wanted to do
Star Wars they said no and he was like
all right I'll just do my own
[Music]
thing so Rebel moons essentially Zack
Snider's rated our Star Wars but not
Star Wars movie Story Goes word around
the campfire is Zack Snider had this
idea for this gritty rated R Star Wars
story took it to Lucas film they were
like we don't want it Netflix was like
you can do it here bring all your Zack
Snider isms to the Star Wars but not
Star Wars world and make it rated PG-13
please and this is for part one a child
on fire so there's always someone on
fire it's always catching fire the girl
on fire child of fire catchy stuff throw
fire in the title you got yourself a win
so the Stars Sophia Bella as in Star
Wars there's big Evil Empire and they're
a fascist Empire they're Space Nazis
difference here is when you see the
outfits you're like oh they're not just
Space Nazis they're Nazis in space it
starts out with his Zack Snider's
attempt at doing SFI intro to in
glorious bastards we come to Sophia
Butella this character who's been hiding
out on this Farm Moon she's got skills
so she sets off to get a team together
to take on the evil empire and when this
movie first started out we're talking
the first world you're on I thought the
CGI was really impressive probably
because it's the first world it's the
hook you want the CGI to be most
impressive in the intro after that the
CGI is kind of intermittent some CGI
looks great other times looks iffy those
tentacles look CGI as [__] also why I
get you're going to pull from Star Wars
you really want to pull from the
tentacles in Rogue one don't do that
that's the scene we skip when we watch
Rogue one some scenes of noticeable
green screen some scenes not but if we
are talking visual flare it's absolutely
in here cuz it's kind of Zack Snider's
wheelhouse also I'm going to do Galactic
scale World building wish me luck but
it'll probably look nice but when I was
on this moon this Imperial generals
being scary Sophia batell is like you
know what back to action I'm going to
take these dudes out and she does I was
like okay why is this movie being being
bagged on by critics this is a pretty
solid start and the movie kept going I
was like okay there are complaints
before I get to the actual complaints
what you need to know about the movie is
it's a Zack Snider Space movie inspired
by Star Wars which was inspired by other
things itself if you're a Zack Snider
fan you're going to be like this has
exactly what I thought it would have if
you don't like Zack Snider you're going
to be like this has exactly what I
thought it would have slowmo shots you
know it
man so many slow-mo shots slowmo shots
jumping in the air slow-mo laser blasts
even the [__] rice dropped on the
ground in slow-mo just gardeners
throwing rice on the ground fur Garden
rice maybe it was seeds doesn't make it
more or less necessary for a slowmo shot
not like anyone got blasted or anything
it was just
gardening I was like somehow I'm not
surprised Michael Bay explosion Zack
Snider slow-mo shots there's one scene
where this dude is on a griffin shirt L
abs are all out just this muscular
handsome dude riding a griffin I was
like I'll give him that there's no one
else out there really making movies that
feel like 80s fantasy cover art is that
Zack Snider paying tribute to artist
Boris vjo I don't know for sure but if I
found out that was the case I would not
be surprised but to its core essentially
the formula of this movie is hop to a
new planet recruit the new character
Exposition dump rinon repeat that
formula until the very end fight and
credits you see Sci-Fi inspiration in
here in a world where a lot of sci-fi
and or video games have pulled from
other sci-fi stories sci-fi fantasy
whatever your flavor I feel like we're
all going to watch this movie and Link
it to something else we're all going to
see different things different
connections for me it felt like a very
rushed Final Fantasy game where you're
going to the different locations you end
up meeting a new character you bring
that new character onto the team thus
your team is building everyone's coming
together for a common goal it's that
crushed into a movie actually was very
Final Fantasy in the sense that everyone
looked different I was going to say felt
different I didn't get to know them well
enough to say they felt different would
have liked to have gotten to know the
characters more it concentrates more on
Sophia Bella's character which ends up
being one of the problems rule of Cinema
show don't tell giving me visual aids
while someone is telling me the
backstory does not count as show that's
still tell and this happens a few times
in the movie you get more Exposition
dump with visual aids to go along with
it something that usually happens at the
beginning of a movie just happens
sequentially throughout this movie there
is intriguing lore in this universe in
the canvas of this galaxy it's just not
delivered to you in a way that feels
organic so in the end is this movie as
good as a Zack SNY fan probably wants it
to be no is it as bad as you might fear
no it's essentially the embodiment of
the difference between potential and
reality because this world has a lot of
potential but the reality of execution
is it's too much to cram into a movie a
smaller band of Heroes that you can can
get to know better and less Exposition
vomit probably would have helped out a
lot you don't really get attached to the
characters except Sophia Bella's
character she's the character that
stands out and whatever he's going to do
with the Droid in the sequel I'm
intrigued to see that but it is solid
Zack Snider visual eye candy there be
the positives maybe by the end of
chapter 2 and all the director Cuts is
going to be a solid fleshed Out World as
it stands right now I think this movie
probably be a solid time if you're drunk
yeah now it's a party I heard there's a
director's cut coming out cuz everything
has a director's cut nowadays but with
Zack Snider I have seen where his
director's cuts are Justified I hope
it's that I hope it's like Batman v
Superman dawn of Justice where you watch
the director's cut and you're like oh so
that's the actual version of the movie
rather than the director's cut of Rebel
Moon part one being oh it's bloodier
people swear and there's more sex that
would just feel wasteful why would he
not just put the rated art director's
cut out first well double the views baby
got to be the reason all so Rebel Moon
part one child of Fire have you seen it
what did you think about it whatever you
thought comment below let me know and as
always if you like what you've seen here
and you want to see more click right
here to see
[Music]
more